تنظم النقابات العماليه في فرنسا مشاهدينا
يوما عاشرا من الاحتجاجات على مستوى
البلاد فيما تستمر الاضرابات بعد ان خيمت
على مسيرات او مسيرات الاسبوع الماضي
اعمال عنف في الشوارع تعد الاسوا منذ
اعوام كما يرى البعض وسيشمل هذا التحرك
الشعبي والنقابي عده قطاعات من بينها
التعليم والصحه والنقل والطاقه وكان اخر
تحرك ضد رفع سن التقاعد الخميس الماضي قد
شهد نزول ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون
متظاهر الى الشوارع في فرنسا وفقا
للنقابات فيما تحدثت وزاره الداخليه حينها
عن حوالي مليون وتسعين الف متظاهر للمزيد
حول ذلك ينضم الينا من باريس مراسل
العربيه حسين جنيبر اهلا بك حسين اذا
انباء تتحدث عن تجدد المظاهرات اليوم حول
سن حول رفع سن التقاعد انقل لدينا اخر
المعلومات لديك
اهلا بك فاطمه بالفعل تظاهر مركزيه ستنطلق
من ساحه الجمهوريه عند الساعه الثانيه من
بعد الظهر ساحه الجمهوريه هنا في باريس
هذه التظاهره المركزيه تتعلق بالعاصمه
وحدها ولكن التحركات الشعبيه والنقابيه
ستشمل اليوم عده مدن كبرى اذكر من بينها
بالاضافه الى باريس اليوم ومارسيليا
وتولوز ونيس وكان بالاضافه الى بوردو
سبور وعددا كبيرا من المدن الاخرى الكبرى
والمتوسطه
والصغرى هذا التحرك ستواكبه القوى الامنيه
من خلال انتشار 13 الف شرطي ودركي عبر
فرنسا من بينهم 5500 سينتشرون في العاصمه
وحدها وزير الداخليه
جيرالنا حذر من وج مخاطره كبيره
الاحتمالات اندلاعي اعمال عنف واخلال
بالنظام العام متحدثا عن وجود حواله الف
عنصر متطرف قال انهم ينتمون الى اليسار
المتطرف بعضهم ينتمي الى اليسار المتطرف
وبعضهم قادم من خارج فرنسا سيلتحقون بموكب
التظاهرات في باريس وهؤلاء بعضهم سيقوم
ايضا باعمال العنف في مدن بوردو
واليون وديجو تحدث وزير الداخليه عن وجود
عناصر من اقصى اليسار ومن اليسار المتطرف
يهدفون الى الحاق الاذى بعناصر الامن وقال
ان
891 شرطيا ودركيا جرحوا في فرنسا منذ
السادس عشر من هذا الشهر في اعمال عنف
توزعت عبر انحاء البلاد واضيف اليهم سبعه
واربعون عنصرا امنيا جرحوا يوم السبت
الماضي في مواجهات اخرى منفصله تتعلق
بالاحتجاج على اقامه مخازن للغايه الزراعي
ابار عفوا وسدود للراي الزراعي طيب هل من
بوادر عن اي تراجع ربما للرئيس عن هذه
القرارات ام هناك اصرار على هذه القرارات
رغم الاحتجاجات
الرئيس حتى الان يبدو مصرا على تنفيذ
قانون سن التقاعد بدءا من شهر ايلول
سبتمبر المقبل لانه يعتبر كما الحكومه ان
نظام التقاعد يعاني من عجز سيبلغ عام 2030
عشرين مليار يورو بفعل ارتفاع معدل اعمار
الفرنسيين المعدل الوسطي للاعمار الذي
ارتفع خلال عقود الاخيره يفرض تمديد العمل
عامين اضافيين من الثانيه والستين الى
الرابعه والستين براي الحكومه المخرج
الوحيد قد يكون من خلال وساطه دعت اليها
النقابات نقابه رئيسيتان دعت الى وساطه
بين هذه النقابات والسلطه التنفيذيه والا
فان الكلمه الاخيره ستكون للمجلس الدستوري
الذي سيبط بالامر بعد ثلاثه اسابيع فاذا
ايد الحكومه ستكون هناك احتمالات باندلاع
مواجهات عنيفه جديده فاطمه شكرا